[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
do
have a seat have a seat everybody
have a seat thank you
thank you thank you so much for your
welcome
and i am both humbled and privileged to
stand before you today
as the leader of the democratic unionist
party we live
in momentous times but throughout it all
i am mindful of the support
and the work of those of you in the hall
and indeed those of you who are
supporters
watching at home today i say
a heartfelt thank you to the members
friends
and supporters of the party for all that
you have done over this past
12 months ultimately politics is about
serving the interests of the people
and shaping the future for the benefit
of everyone
and that must be our guiding principle
now of course i want to have my personal
welcome to boris for joining with us and
addressing
our conference thank you so much and
and i also want to put on record my
appreciation to the chancellor philip
hammond for speaking
at our conference dinner last evening
the dup
has and will continue to work with a
range of parliamentarians
on the national stage to further the
national interest
i am delighted as well to have a
delegation from gibraltar
who have traveled to participate in our
conference this weekend
and it is fitting that we launched our
friends of gibraltar grouping
earlier on i had the pleasure of playing
a wonderful visit to gibraltar in
september and meeting with the chief
minister fabian becardo
conference i was enthused by the passion
and the pride the people of gibraltar
have for their home
and for their britishness we understand
that passion
and pride and today conference we stand
with the people and the government of
gibraltar at this difficult time
now we are fortunate to have mr johnson
with us this afternoon he has
strong electoral appeal possesses youth
and energy
and has a big political future no not
you boris
but councillor peter johnson our newly
elected representative in carrick fergus
let me again congratulate peter and the
east anthem team
on that by-election victory we were all
delighted
when peter gained an extra seat for the
party taking what had been an
independent seat
and pushing the dup vote share in the
area
up by 12 with a 40 first preference
advantage
over the nearest rival candidate and
peter is not our only new addition
at council level i also want to offer a
very warm dup
welcome to alderman sharon mckillip from
causeway coast and glam scouting
sharon has this week left the tuv and
joined the democratic unionist party and
we're delighted to have you here today
sharon
so sharon sharon recognizes
that it is this party that delivers for
the people and it is this party
that has the plan for the future
now today we meet at a time of
unprecedented interest in our party
the brexit negotiation is the current
dominant political issue
and i want to thank all those colleagues
who are involved in that ongoing work
i want to express my gratitude in
particular
to nigel for his leadership at
westminster
and indeed i want to thank all of my
parliamentary team for the work that
they do
but at this point i want to take a
moment to say a special thank you
for the work that our member of the
european parliament dianne dodds has
undertaken
now by the time by the time of the
united kingdom's departure diane will
have been an advocate for northern
ireland
in europe for a decade and i know like
me you appreciate diane's hard work and
dedication
on behalf of the people of northern
ireland diane occasionally likes to
remind us that it was she who joined the
party first
and later persuaded nigel to join
for that alone i am eternally grateful
but after her election in 2009 diane
established a public facing european
office
and her hard work and results for
constituents
were subsequently regarded rewarded at
the ballot box
diane has provided an unparalleled
service to the people of northern
ireland and i know
that diane will continue to play a very
important role
in the years to come conference we stand
at a crucial moment in the affairs of
our nation
our party has been entrusted with great
responsibility
as a result of the votes of the people
across northern ireland
and with that responsibility comes a
greater focus
on our party than we have ever known
before
people are interested to know our policy
positions on a range of issues
and more than ever the views of our
party representatives are sought
so we must say what we mean and mean
what we say
and so today i want at the outset to
publicly address the issue of the
renewable heat incentive scheme
and our handling of it during our time
in government
now this has been a very difficult
period for our party
in particular and for northern ireland
politics as a whole
my motivation in government was always
to do
the right thing at the right time and
for the right reasons
but the best of intentions doesn't make
you immune from mistakes
or misjudgments and some of our past
decisions and actions have left a lot to
be desired
and i know that they have personally
hurt and offended
many of our members voters and the
public
the public inquiry has been difficult
for many individually
and painful for the party collectively
no party would want to have all of its
dealings exposed for all to see
at a public inquiry especially in the
unique system of government we have with
the struggles and strains
required to make it work but i make no
excuses
today as leader of this party i
apologize
as a
as a party we are deeply deeply sorry
for the mistakes we made and for the
things we got wrong
during that period and i am determined
our party will learn the lessons from
the rhi
and how government business was
conducted at stormont more generally
now there are many lessons to learn
these lessons such as ensuring that we
have
the best people appointed to ministerial
office and that all our representatives
are clear
on what is required of them lessons
about special advisors
how we appoint special advisors the
number required and how they operate and
are regulated in government
lessons for the civil service there is a
strong case
for a fundamental appraisal of the
northern ireland civil service
and consideration of extending the home
civil service
to northern ireland with technology
increasing complexity
and the emergence of new approaches
particularly those which intersect with
the private sector
greater expertise is going to be
required
we also have lessons about openness and
transparency
proper records must be kept and we must
recognize that greater transparency will
add
value to public debate but you know
simply changing
processes and procedures will not
be enough we must go further and ensure
that we are engaged in an
ongoing process of renewal and
self-examination
now we will work hard to make amends and
regain the support and trust of those
who were upset by what they saw
unfolding over this last number of
months and i know
i also speak for many when i say that
over the course of this last 12 months
there have been a number of other areas
where our behavior in our ranks has not
matched the standards expected of people
holding public office so we must ensure
that there is no repeat of such behavior
and that those high standards we aspire
to ourselves
and that others rightly require of us
are applicable at every level
within this party and while mistakes
were made
there were many decisions taken by
ministers from this party
and other parties that we can be proud
of and which ensured northern ireland
kept moving in the right direction
records
record levels of inward investment
billions invested in new roads
new schools and new hospitals but of
course
much more remains to be done our country
and our people deserve a stable
government
that will focus on taking decisions to
make a real
and meaningful difference to the lives
of our people up and down our country
[Applause]
the conference as we look to the future
the union
is the best political social economic
and cultural foundation to lay for the
next generation
why do i say that because through our
union with great britain
we can contribute to and benefit from
being a constituent part of one of the
oldest democracies
we can contribute to and benefit from
public services and safety nets
many other countries cannot match for
example our fantastic national health
service
we can contribute to and have the
protection of
one of the largest economies in the
world and we can contribute to
and benefit from a cultural wealth the
envy
of the rest of the globe and all of this
was achieved
not by one constituent part of the
united kingdom alone
but by the efforts and talents of all of
them
all of us
all of this was achieved through our
common bond
the union and when we look back over our
proud history and our common struggles
we see what we achieved was because we
did it together
as a united kingdom and that is what
shapes
our vision for leaving the european
union
our commitment to the principles of
democracy
means that we must implement the
referendum result of 2016.
a national referendum with a national
outcome
and our
[Applause]
and our commitment to the common good
for all parts of the united kingdom
means we must leave as one nation and
that we must work collectively
to make it a success our common
history teaches us that the united
kingdom has
and will continue to be a global success
we've done it before
and can do so again two years ago
at conference i outlined five simple
principles that would guide us
in brexit discussions and stated that
talks would be tough
seems like a bit of an understatement
now i have to say
but in particular i said that the
economic and social benefits for
northern ireland within the united
kingdom
are far more important than our
relationship with the european union
and that we would work with whomever in
order to get the best deal
for northern ireland at home and abroad
now consistently we have indicated our
objectives
and our bottom line they were simple
they were clear
and they were focused we sought to do
what was best for the united kingdom
and northern ireland in particular we
sought to provide the government with
the room it needed to negotiate
but never to lose sight of what it
needed to deliver
and most importantly we publicly and
privately indicated
that we could not support proposals that
would open
the possibility of divergence in either
customs
or regulatory measures between great
britain and northern ireland
our message was clear and it was
consistent
now conference i do want to acknowledge
the hard work and determined efforts of
the prime minister
to secure an agreement i believe she is
genuine
when she says she wants to see an
outcome that does no harm to the union
and the internal market of the united
kingdom
however this draft agreement fails her
own
key commitments the prime minister has
not been able to guarantee an outcome
that eliminates the risk of the
introduction
of the so-called backstop arrangements
now
on the one hand we're told that the
backstop would be the best of both
worlds
and on the other hand we're told we're
not going to need the backstop
so ladies and gentlemen therein lies one
of the many contradictions
at the heart of this draft withdrawal
agreement
in such circumstances northern ireland
alone
would be aligned to numerous eu single
market regulations
while great britain would not such a
scenario
in the medium term would inevitably lead
to barriers to trade
within the united kingdom internal
market
let me be very clear that is not in the
national
interest
now i know that there are many in the
business community in northern ireland
who are frustrated with the piece of
negotiations
and the politics around it and who
simply seek
certainty i understand their position
they have been clear that they would
prefer what is currently on the table
rather than a no deal outcome but for us
we cannot wish away the fact that the
draft withdrawal agreement contains
arrangements
that we believe are not in northern
ireland long-term
economic or strategic interests northern
ireland would remain
part of the european union's customs
code and as things stand
we would be sowing the seed of
inevitable economic divergence
from our largest market in addition in
addition to the economic arguments of
course we believe the constitutional
implications
of the deal cannot be ignored
the democratic unionist party has never
been afraid to say yes when it is right
to do so
nor to say no when required
and we do not stand alone on these
issues with a large number of
conservatives both those who want to
leave and remain
not persuaded even jeremy corbyn isn't
buying the sea border
but this party wants to see a negotiated
and orderly withdrawal from the european
union that's always been our position
we're not campaigning for a no deal exit
nor do we want
barriers to trade between northern
ireland and our neighbours in the
republic
the choice is not between this deal and
no deal
despite what the government spin machine
may say
the reality is that if we are to secure
a better outcome than is currently on
offer
then the only option is to look beyond
the current draft withdrawal agreement
and work in the time ahead for an
improved outcome
this party acted responsibly in the
national interest to secure a government
in 2017 and we will not be found wanting
in our efforts to secure
a better outcome an outcome
that does not leave northern ireland
open to the perils of
increased divergence away from the rest
of the united kingdom
an outcome which instead truly works
to the benefit of all parts of this
great nation
now the days and weeks ahead will be
challenging
but we will continue to work in
parliament
to achieve the best possible deal for
northern ireland and
the united kingdom as a whole guided by
our principles
and by our objectives conference
this party has come a long way
since the days when dr paisley and a
small band of faithful men
and women stepped out to form the ulster
democratic unionist party
we are at the center of political life
in northern ireland and the united
kingdom
and we have the opportunity to shape the
future
but we must ensure we translate our
vision into a reality
and our unionism must deliver to the
benefit of everyone
in northern ireland that is why when the
confidence and supply agreement gave us
the opportunity
to contribute so integrally to our
nation's affairs
and deliver for northern ireland we did
so
and we insisted by the way on delivering
for
everyone in northern ireland let me give
you a few examples
which are not often talked about if you
know
a child or a parent who has benefited
through sure start
or extended school supervision those
services
are being funded through the money which
we secured to tackle deprivation
in the confidence and supply agreement
indeed this year
and i'm really proud of this an
additional 10 million pounds was able to
be provided
to improve mental health services ladies
and gentlemen
delivering for the people we represent
is what shapes our vision for devolution
we want to use the flexibilities that
devolution
provides to make northern ireland even
better
for all and our vision does not end at
the steps of stormont
our councils have larger budgets and
staff teams
than some government departments and
more pars
than ever before we see their untapped
potential
and that working alongside a restored
assembly
and taking forward city deals can only
help
drive northern ireland forward
at local government our plan is not just
for low rates and quality services
but also to make a meaningful difference
to our society
next may voters will have the
opportunity to elect new councils
for the next four-year mandate and the
democratic unionist party will field a
strong team
of local government candidates that will
combine use
and experience as always we will offer
voters the chance to return candidates
to councils who will deliver quality
services
without overburdening the ratepayers
now the 11 new councils have almost
completed their first full term in
office
and i recognize that the creation of the
new councils has not been without its
difficulties
and none more so than in the west of
northern ireland where
minority unionist communities have not
been respected
and where the equality agenda has done
little to support unionist culture
and identity and as we move forward
we are determined i am determined to
spotlight this
issue and work to ensure that those who
shout the loudest
about respect and equality practice what
they preach
beyond beyond local government and we're
all looking forward to getting out to
canvas
beyond local government we want to see
the executive and assembly
re-established
on a sustainable basis this party the
dup
is a pro-devolution party since we
became the largest party of unionism the
dep has prioritized the establishment
and maintenance of a working executive
and assembly as its core
political priority this remains
unchanged
i am as committed to devolution today as
i was the day the institution stopped
functioning
because influence in london or par in
belfast
was never a binary choice in fact both
working together
is when we can achieve the most for
northern ireland
and devolution is good for northern
ireland
while securing a stable administration
is we know challenging
local decision making by those who live
here
is by far the best option
throughout 2007 to 2017
the dup persisted through every
challenge
every time there was a substantive
roadblock we sought to work through each
one
and achieve a balanced agreement now
there were many times
it would have been easy to walk away but
we
didn't throughout the dep
understood that dealing with the
problems from within
an executive and assembly was always the
better course
and history will clearly show what we
achieved in that decade was so much more
than what had preceded it the successes
of the 10 years of an executive were
generally characterized by the power of
a series of decisions
that flowed from locally accountable
ministers
however we cannot disguise the fact that
too many of the big decisions
were either avoided or started and never
finished
it took a decade of negotiations to
create a stable executive
we now need 10 years of genuine change
and of transformative government the
case for change
is not limited to our politics and
institutions
but change is required in how we work
together with other parties and
coalition
and how that coalition works with the
civil service
in any new northern ireland
administration and during talks that
might bring one about
i want all parties to have their
mandates respected
and i will encourage the full
involvement of all parties capable of
holding
ministerial office and want their
contribution considered
and acted upon on its merits
the dep will step up its engagement with
the secretary of state
and with the other parties to chart a
way forward
and when stormont does return we need to
demonstrate that it is with the
intention of
making the big decisions and that we
will all operate
with genuine collective responsibility
clearly there needs to be
more certainty that the institutions
will be robust
and withstand political pressure and a
northern ireland executive should be
established on the basis
of a concise agreed coalition plan for
government
such an agreement needs to address the
fundamentals
of our nhs and our education system
in education we must ensure more funding
is targeted at the classrooms and that
where necessary
we do not shy away from taking difficult
decisions if that
is what is in the best interest of
pupils and staff
on health we prepared more plans for
reform
than actual reforms we ever implemented
and
any new executive must be on the basis
of the implementation of the bengal
report and we must ensure funding
earmarked for health
goes to health we must also be conscious
that there is a lack of cultural
security
primarily for unionists but also for
others
we need a new cultural deal for everyone
in northern ireland
that respects difference and fosters
understanding
because it is in unionism's interests
for those from all backgrounds to feel
comfortable in a northern ireland at
peace with itself
the result will be in northern ireland
with effective functioning devolved
government
making a tangible difference to people's
lives
now as the largest party of unionism and
the party of northern ireland
the mantle for change and delivery
natural
naturally falls at our feet and we have
never shirked
the opportunity to lead before and we
will not do so now
the size the breadth and the depth of
our team
set us apart and give us confidence that
we can rise to the challenges
that lie ahead and we have much work to
do in the year ahead
any successful political party wants the
fullest possible range of voters
and potential voters and our broader
responsibility to unionism
must guide our behavior
supporters of the union and i'm looking
out at you all
come in all shapes and sizes
we always need to be seeking to attract
the maximum number of voters to the
unionist cause
and our overarching strategic task is to
sell the benefits of the union
and persuade a new generation of our
people
that it is a union that works for them
as it has for us
we have the vision the plan
and the team to deliver for northern
ireland
now is the time to learn the lessons
from the past
look forward to the future and shape it
with confidence
and determination i stand here believing
that with our westminster team
with our assembly team with our
counselors and with each and every one
of you
that we can achieve it all for the
people
for the country and for the union let us
keep
focused as we lead and let us never lose
sight
that we have a historic responsibility
to lay
solid foundations for the next
generation
conference that a stand strong for
northern ireland thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
where is tomorrow
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you